this rail project is our bridge to
nowhere it's very hard really at this
point to stop it with politics and
reason more cars and hours stuck in
traffic that's the reality facing
Honolulu drivers our highways are
clogged with traffic costing us eighty
billion dollars a year in lost
productivity and wasted fuel
well Honolulu has one of the worst
traffic congestion in the United States
it's almost like a mini version of Los
Angeles Ben Cayetano was a popular
two-term governor of the state of Hawaii
and like governor's all across the
country has spent a lot of time trying
to understand the state's crippling
traffic problem worse than la worse than
Manhattan a new study on our congestion
is providing fresh fodder for the debate
over mass transit in 2011 with the
support of the Federal Transit
Administration the city of Honolulu
decided to begin construction on a
massive elevated rail line initially
budgeted for 3.7 billion dollars in 2005
had now ballooned to an estimated 5.3
billion federal and hawaii leaders made
it official with a stroke of a pen
Honolulu's rail transit project the
first ever for Hawaii gets one point 55
billion federal dollars one thing about
these projects they're very inviting
politically to support the problem is
often that when local developers
politicians and labor unions fight for
federal investment money the incentive
is to get the most expensive project and
not the most efficient solution the
proposed rail project will spend just
twenty miles from a popular shopping
mall to the lesser populated island area
of Kapolei this is the people's train
this is a train that needs to be built
sooner rather than later and the state
needs the revenues the sold the project
and the idea that it would be reduced
traffic congestion and of course it was
never about that
it's about development there's a lot of
money to be made in the construction and
once it started we're convinced that it
will be billions of dollars over budget
and we think they'll try to get the
federal government to bail them out and
in any event it's going to cost local
taxpayers a minimum of four billion
dollars we think it's going to be closer
to six or seven billion dollars Randal
Roth is a law professor at the
University of Hawaii and along with
former governor Ben Cayetano
and transportation expert cliff Slater
at Honolulu traffic calm this wasn't a
decision based on merit as this was
strictly a political decision have filed
a federal lawsuit alleging that the city
did not conduct a thorough or honest
appraisal of the Transportation
Alternatives the lawsuits both state and
federal I believe eventually will force
the city to try to comply if they really
do make a good faith effort to comply
what they'll determine is that rail is
is the least attractive of the
alternatives that are available the
critics which include virtually every
environmental group in Hawaii claim the
city misled the public about the rail
line that will cost too much and do
little to ease congestion now is the
time we need to get this rail project
there's a political dimension to all of
these projects which is why you know you
find that they usually end up costing
40% more than what is projected and
usually the ridership projections are
far less than what they tell the local
officials it will be you don't have the
taxpaying population you don't have the
demand you don't have the need pan
asprova Doros
is a civil engineer a professor and
hawaii dean transportation expert I was
in the first committee that actually
assessed the alternatives analysis this
alternatives analysis is closer to a
joke rather than a scientific study if
you actually look at the studies in the
EIS by my own calculation the number of
trips is going to reduce on Oahu is 1.7
percent even if you focus on specific
congested parts of the corridor it will
never do more than 5% the point of doing
any cost-effectiveness type of analysis
is out of the window
benefits are not there for the long run
this project will probably end up like
tren Urbano in Puerto Rico we share
about an 80% costs overrun and they
projected 80,000 people average
ridership there are 25,000 basically our
congestion is quite predictable we have
very acute points and nobody's doing
anything about them predictable because
Hawaii's roadway system is under built
and deteriorating on a per capita basis
no other state in the country has fewer
Lane miles than Hawaii ninety percent of
Hawaii's state-owned major roads have
fallen out of good condition as of 2008
there are a number of more attractive
alternatives which ironically and I say
that with a smile because this is why a
lot of people and who I don't like it
there'd be a lot less expensive than
rail solutions about I mean we have
among the most congested freeways
because we're developing areas and we
are not addressing critical bottlenecks
in seven all of them an investment in
the order of a few dozen million dollars
not billion million twelve million here
50 million there will actually provide
substantial relief to other congestion
we have panel says a far cheaper and
even more energy efficient way to
improve mobility would be to have wider
roadways increased Lane miles and basic
road maintenance even further manage
toll roads could bring much-needed
private infrastructure investment to the
state along with a rien phasis on
improving the already popular and
underfunded bus system bus has two
significant advantages low price
comparatively speaking particularly for
the startup and tremendous flexibility
Honolulu is meandering around the shore
and in the valleys and regions etc you
need the flexibility of buses to get
there and then you need BRT along major
trunk corridors to connect your major
points in the plan that actually the
feds approved the project uses over 100
million dollars of future funds to buy
buses fifty percent roughly of the
future ridership of the rail
we'll be bus and BRT traffic congestion
in Hawaii will be worse with this rail
project than what it is today a little
bit better than if we did absolutely
nothing
over the next 12 years and yet they sold
it to the people of Hawaii as a solution
to today's traffic congestion problems
the city collects money for sewers and
water and although we are operating
under an EPA consent decree to fix our
sewers they have essentially mortgaged
that part of the money and said that if
there are unpredictable cost overruns
for the rail they will take the sewer
money and sink it in the rail well what
will happen and I predict is they're
going to end up raising taxes either
that or the city will go bankrupt
we've still got too many rail lines that
are too slow and clogged up we've still
got too many roads that are in disrepair
too many bridges that aren't safe or we
can build better and in a time of tight
budgets we've got to do it in a way that
make sure taxpayer dollars are spent
wisely they'd like to see greater
scrutiny and accountability by the
federal government when they give money
to projects nobody looks beyond the life
of the project and I think that the
people are going to pay a big price for
curbside bus came on with a storm at
East Coast Pittsburgh Atlanta now Texas
really for people that like cities
something to celebrate indeed the
curbside bus industry has grown an
exceptionally rapid rate but the safety
regime has failed to keep pace the state
is putting the brakes on Fung Wah bus
weary Asst safety problems across its
entire fleet so you really want to
encourage bus travel and the temptation
governments I think is we got to be able
to control this